let's keep it moving and talk top gun
maverick because yesterday the cast took
over the cannes film festival and got a
five minute standing ovation after the
movie ended it is that good y'all and
today the cast hit the uk with our
rachel smith
i am in london right now hanging out
with mr top gun himself tom cruise and i
can confirm the rumors are true tom is
just as charming in person as everyone
says he
[Music]
all is here we go
maverick the ultimate aviator you sir
are the ultimate actor trying to deliver
for you okay
causing a collective uk freak out the
king of action held court with prince
william and duchess kate the royals went
full hollywood glam tom helped kate up
the steps in her off-the-shoulder black
and white gown i hear william is a top
gun fanatic is this true that you've
already given him an advanced screening
of the film so this will be a second
time soon yes early on it was an aviator
so i know you'd have a lot of fun have
the two of you ever flown together not
yet
[Laughter]
get ready pilots are pilots so we all
wanna we all wanna go flying
and william has had his own maverick
moments during his time as a helicopter
pilot check out their near identical
saluting uniform that's a royal
for me this is really a once in a
lifetime experience where do you go from
here i think it's all downhill from here
who'd you piss off this time another
admiral
topper gun maverick hits theaters may
27th and glen pal certainly understood
the assignment when it comes to drumming
up buzz with this steamy selfie follow
me
girlfriend gigi perez commented quote
i'm burning all your shirts it's really
nice to see you with a shirt on i
thought your girlfriend burned all your
shirts you know what i'm thank god she
didn't because it's uh it'd be a little
cold here i don't know and it's a royal
occasion yes yeah i'm not supposed to
meet the royals without a shirt on
[Music]